hi my name is double Solomon and I'm
presenting a walk about the homomorphic
encryption the good stopping involving
encryption via functional encryption and
this work is uh currently with a little
bit Lansky from Tel Aviv University
um so I'll start with the motivation and
the the settings for homomorphic
encryption
so we have
um secret message m
and we want to compute a some function f
over M we want someone else to compute
the function the function f for us
and all of this without revealing the
message and
so this has a very practical aspect
aspect in the cloud settings well we
want the cloud provider to compute some
function for us
um and this is also very useful in the
theoretical settings for example in a
multi-party computations
and verifiable delegation and the zero
knowledge protocols
so um let's discuss the definition
we start with the level of encryption
so we have uh for algorithms a region
and encryption encryption and eval
um scheme has a thematic security
meaning an encryption of a zero is
indistinguishable form an encryption of
one
the scheme supports a leveled
homomorphism homologism meaning that
even an encryption key an encryption key
and the evaluation key sampled by the
general algorithm
a message M and the Circuit of the F at
most L then we can homographically
evaluate a silicate and the grip and
encrypt a
the evaluated the cycle text the output
of the circuit on that message
and note uh this this is called a level
homomorphism because the algorithms May
uh depend on L they get can get it as a
parameter for example the then algorithm
can get a l as a parameter
organization we need compactness meaning
that the size of evaluated title text is
a proportional to the size of the output
of the circuit on the m
um right now we have many uh
instructions for NWA from standard
assumptions for example if an lattices
from wa and rlwe
and they also from a public exponential
one-way function in this in addition to
sub-exponential of exponential AIO
um the next step is describing a fully
automation so essentially it's the same
syntax as a level of application with
one difference at the
algorithms
doesn't get L is a parameter and instead
it can operate
correctly
for any circuit which has a nominal
therefore every family of circuits with
a polynomial layer
so
um our work is about wood slipping
um which is essentially transforming in
leveled on office scheme into a fully
homomorphic one
um and it's kind of like in the Digimon
series TV show well you have like a cute
little Digimon and then you have a
digivolution upgrade the the Q Digimon
into some uh mighty Beast
so let's distract this uh this uh
discuss the previous techniques so uh
maybe the first one is uh using a
secular security which goes back to uh
entries work in 2009
then we have
um some years later
work which
um
created bus stopping out of
sub-exponential narratives
and then we have uh bootstopping from
nominal i o in addition to Elf or Alpha
can be constructed from Financial ADH
and the io
um on its own is from a sub-exponential
functional encryption
and also we have some construction some
bootstrapping techniques from some other
forms of a
non-studal forms of a functional
encryption
so in our work uh we present a new
bootstrapping technique from a
polynomial assumptions
um for Universe uniform adversary it's a
polynomial functional encryption
and more precisely giving a semi-compact
public functional encryption uh we can
bootstrap a
um a level scheme
which can evaluate any Circ any which
can evaluate its own decryption circuit
into a foliomorphic one
um we can also uh how technique also
works for non-uniform adversaries but
worse with but we need also to assume
eth in a uniforming ph and to be precise
um
yeah so we need some sort of General
this time allergy theorem which is
implied from a non-uniform eth
and also our technique and security
proof is also on and uses a in a black
box reduction
so uh let's start with the uh Gentry's
bootstrapping
so
the the key idea is a budget
a level domorphic encryption meaning an
a level scheme that can evaluate
its own a
is the death of the decryption and
circuit plus one
so in this technique we have to Cipher
text
ct0 suffer text of m0 and ct1 such
effective M1
we also have an encryption of a a
decryption key zero under the encryption
key one
and we have gentlest function and
which is a decryption of the first
Cipher text and decryption and then none
and with the description of the second
cycle text
and then the the key inside is that we
can homomorphically evaluate this
function with the the this Cipher text
and the the cipher text of the
decryption key and when we decrypt it
under dk1 it decrypts to the nand of m0
and N1
so in a sense we switch from encryption
other under the the first
encryption key to an encryption under
the second one
and and then you can use this insight
and apply it inductively
and we can define a chain of this uh
encryption the encryption of a of a
secret key under under some of the
decryption key under some encryption key
and we will call it the the key chain so
the first element in the keychain is the
encryption of the first decryption key
under the second encryption key then we
have a decrypt an encryption of the
second decryption key under the third
encryption key and so on
and so in Gentry's bootstrapping the
circuit is a
described as a
series of uh as a and we're using a some
Universal egg hey for example not Gates
um
in the during evaluation of evaluation
the if level is available evaluated
using a Gentry's function and if the if
evaluation key which is again the
encryption of the uh if minus one
decryption key under the IFA encryption
key
foreign
need to publish
so if we publish all of them well we can
um perform homomorphic evaluation up to
delft L and all this is this achieves a
level of encryption scheme
the solution gently solution is to
compress it into a single regression
so instead of publishing instead of
having a chain we we collapse the chain
we close the chain and collapse it into
a single key in single evaluation key
where we encrypt the decryption key
under its own encryption key
and we need a circular security
assumption so this is called the
circular security well we assume that
the encryption scheme is secured even
given this evaluation key
and unfortunately uh there is no
reduction from this scheme into lattices
problems
so in a sense we have we we have a chain
and we collapse it into
um a single key like we close the chain
a we we close the chain
the next idea is to avoid circular
security via
um sub-exponential Primitives
so the idea is we have the key chain we
have a key chain uh with some super
polynomial length
and the the idea is to compress the
kitchen so remember we can't publish
this entire a keychain up front because
it's it's too long
so instead we complete we compress it so
the the compression is as follows we
derive all Randomness from a prf uh more
a precise the format prf
and then we publish a an IO in the
indistinguishability obscation of a
circuit that on input I outputs the I
evaluation key
for in and we allow the circuit to
accept the I from a super polynomial
range
so here we have the devaluation key so
we have the the input I and the C the
circuit uh has in in its stomach uh some
seed to a prf to actually a punctual plf
and it it computes the the IFA
evaluation key which is an encryption of
of
the iPhone decryption key under the IFA
encryption key and all this and this
circuit is is obfuscated
the idea for the Also let's discuss our
intuition for the security both the idea
is to go to the first uh over the the
chain over time and indices the chain
from a super formic stand and some the
polynomial position to the beginning
and in hybrid k
um for every uh input I which is a a k o
bigger than K we return we just return
an encryption of zero and
otherwise we return a valid and
a
evaluation key
and when we get to k equals one let's
see this circuit doesn't leak the first
decryption key anymore and we can apply
to the
underlying
um
a semantic security of the skin
however not this uh
um
this bootstrapping technique requires a
sub-exponential security
uh there uh do we precise there are two
sources of super polynomial blocks
so first of all there are many hybrids
there are super polynomial number of
hybrids um
one per input
and then secondly
um so io on its own
um encourage the laws proportional to
the size of the
input space of the circuit and in fact
this is conjectured to be earned so this
is known for current Construction Supply
but it's a conjecture to be inherent
and unfortunately in the in this
technique there there is a single
circuit with the a super polynomial
number of inputs and so it requires a
sub exponential i o security
so in our work we want to avoid the
super polynomial loss and uh and we are
doing so in two ways
um so the first one we only do a
polynomial number of hybrids and
secondly we we use IO for secrets for
circuits with the polynomial number of
things
so let's discuss how we achieve the
polynomial number of hybrids
the idea is the the high level idea
is instead of going in the chain from
the end to the beginning
um start the hybrid somewhere in the
middle say say in some polynomial
position p
and then we go in reverse from P to one
and every time change a
a one node in the chain
and
so and the question is uh well in the
sociability so given an adversary why if
we okay if we go if we started in the
end we can apply the previous technique
but why we can start in the middle right
so why the adversary can can't
distinguish
and then another question is well well
we need to start what's what's P
so the idea is to to use the time lock
puzzles
so
um a quick reminder about puzzles so we
encrypt some message to the Future
um so we get a message the parameters of
some message M and the time parameter t
and the the the encryption phase takes
time much less than T and encryption can
can be done a
and
and can be done deterministically uh in
time t
so we are using a relaxed version a
relaxed version so we don't
um uh care about the concurrency and we
just care about the size of the
adversary so the security is that any
adversary which is which is
polynomically
smaller than T can't really uh
distinguish between two messages
um luckily we can construct a such a
reluctant log puzzles from a
a very simple assumptions we are very
standard assumptions so namely we need
randomized we need to to marry crypto
with complexity so we we use randomized
encoding which can be based on a
standard polynomial function encryption
and we need complexity so we need time
our hierarchy so for uniform adversaries
uh this is a unconditional we have an
unconditional primary key and for
non-uniform adversaries we need an
assumption
namely we need the assumption that for
every C and P isn't the subset
of infinitely often size circuit size of
entity
and now this assumption is implied for
example for from a
a non-uniformic age
so using these puzzles we augmented the
construction
so instead now instead of just the
circuit
publishing in the encryption of the
decryption key to erupt it with the
puzzle type the puzzle
and note the the difficulty of the
puzzle increases with the impedances
so the the IFA and the iPhone evaluation
key has a puzzle of difficulty I
so now
um we we have our chain and we set a
sample you know so when we have some
polynomial which depends on the
polynomial index which depends on the
size the adversely
um
and then we can change the
index
and because of a puzzle security the
adversity can distinguish between this
this change and this change
okay so now let's say I discuss how we
use only we use IO only for a circuits
with the polynomial
input size
so the idea is instead of using a single
circuit we split it into into many
circuits and for example into into
Lambda a number of circuits where Lambda
is there a secure the parameter
and then
um
the idea is that the the the the if the
the the the the cave circuit accepts uh
inputs of size K and we split the chain
so we first need to get all this the
evaluation keys from the first Circle
and then from the second circuit and
then from the third and so on till we
get into the last circuit
so we have like this uh every circuit is
is is responsible for some some a part
of the chain and the the adversary
um
which has some size can't escape can't
uh
really understand what's going on in
some inside in the output of some
circuit in the middle which is a again
polynomial in size adversary and this
and this circuit has only polynomial a
number of input and we can use IO for
for this circuit and all the
previous circuit and all of them has
only
um polynomial a number of inputs
and yeah so and that's it that was the
taste of our technique and I encourage
you to read the paper for a more formal
uh
description of the of our algorithm and
our technique and
the
security
thank you